[Music]
on today's show we talked to a woman who
wants to know can i tell my husband to
get a new job
we talked to a mother of two young kids
who wants to model appropriate cell
phone usage
and we talk about the age-old question
of friendships and marriage and how to
make it all work stay tuned
[Music]
hey what's up what's up this is john
with the dr john deloney's show
so glad that you're with us
talking about relationships mental
health parenting
what in the world we're doing
i don't know but if you do give us a
shout give us a shot
[Music]
1-844-693-3291 i think i'm gonna i'm
gonna have a segment on the show
where i ask a question and y'all can
call in and just answer it for me
because some things are just soap on
curtis right now i
i don't even know man i do know this i
know a couple things number one shout
out to
my friend he is 11. his name is collier
he's in west texas he's my buddy's son
he had his 11th birthday yesterday
and it's so
great
um todd on the list are two of my oldest
best friends on the planet
and they had
the birthday party planned and they were
all the kids got out early so they were
just gonna go to the park and have a
birthday party at the park that started
at noon when school got out and my buddy
todd thought sweet like
i'll be at home by 1 30.
and melissa put on the invitations
till 5.
12 to 5.
so if you're a parent like me you
probably just dropped your kid off and
you're like oh my gosh i have a whole
afternoon and they got a half day this
is so great
and
my friend todd just was wrangling
511 year olds yesterday
and so starting at about four i started
texting him saying i hope there's just
one kid left i hope every parent has
picked up their kid and there's just one
kid and he's just looking at you and
your kid is tired all the kids are tired
and then at five and then it's six and i
just been texting all night i hope
there's just still one kid sitting at
the park and you're like i hate my life
but anyway shout out to collier and
shout out to jennifer
she just walked into the studio if
you're listening on the podcast that's
got weird for you just keep walking keep
back whatever it is you're doing but
jennifer's here she is the gangster she
is
she's just the editor in my heart
it's good to see you jennifer you make
my heart feel good
we ate we got i hit send last night
it's a big moment i don't even know what
that means for everybody listening i had
a big book draft due last night and so
we're working on the big new book and
hit send so i'm excited to have that
into
somebody else's head and out of my soul
james said he could tell on my face
i don't know what that means hurt my
feelings a little bit but that look my
face looks like an old catcher like in a
good way like you look like you know
you've you've had a week where you've
got a lot done
every time i've seen you this week
you've been sprinting through the
hallway with a determined look on your
face so i can tell
that you probably feel very fulfilled
right now i i take a nap i think that is
the exact same tone of voice that you
use when your wife's like i got my
haircut three days ago and you didn't
say anything and you're like um i just
have seen you with the determined
beautiful look in your heart i feel like
that's what happened hey and before we
go on to the calls
so shout out to collier shout out to
jennifer
keep digging your holes james i got
these two cards yesterday in the mail
not the m-a-l-e in the m-a-i-l and dude
they are watercolors
one of them says hello friend and one of
them says the world needs more of you
and so i'm going to read them
this is so awesome
dear dr dolony i'm rebecca i'm 10 years
old and i'm homeschooled shout out
rebecca for school we have to write a
letter i'm writing to you because you
said if people write you a letter with
pen and paper you will read it on the
air you wrote with pencil but i'm gonna
let it let it go
i'd like for you to know about my family
dad works from home it helps me with
math mom loves listening to you and
she's a great cook i see what you your
little subtle dig there dad's not into
the show i'm cool with that i have three
sisters
and then there's their names we have two
dogs
junipero
and huckleberry we also have a beta his
name is coastal
it's pretty kind of on the nose there
rebecca but whatever and a cat named
anakin
skywalker the evil one i see what you
did there too i love it i love my family
and pets sincerely rebecca shout out
you should not be letting your 10 year
old listen to the show but i digress the
next card dear dr deloney i'm
kaylee i'm 11 years old for school we
have to write a letter i'm writing to
you because my mom loves you
and i want you to know about my family
you have the same mom and dad clearly
your dad's not a fan dad shake it off
man quit drinking the haterade we have
two dogs and a cat and a fish we adopted
a sister
i like how you put sister after the fish
we love
toys
my family is special to me because we
spend a lot of time together sincerely
kaylee rebecca kaylee
man i get lots of mail
ever since
we talked about mail i get letters and
people pour their hearts out these made
my whole day yesterday so thank you
rebecca and kaylee
don't let your kids listen to this show
for god's sakes but also send the
letters that's pretty awesome all right
let's go to dawn in huntington wv what's
up huntington not huntington what's up
don how are you
good how are you thank you for taking my
call thanks for calling i'm a bit much
this morning i'm sorry
hey it's okay how are we doing how we
doing
i'm good awesome so what's up
uh well my question is is it wrong if i
ask my husband to quit his job
i don't know maybe is he like an escort
or a dancer then i would say for sure
thank god
you're like yeah that's probably not the
job for him is he not he's not very good
at dancing
um no i don't think he can fart
that wouldn't be his thing why do you
want him to quit
i get to call i get this opposite call
usually like hey can my husband won't
for god's sakes will get a job
um why do you want your husband to quit
well of course i want him to have a job
but he's he's away six days a week
what's he doing right now well he's a
pipeliner
a pipe welder
pipe
pipeliner sorry can't oh pipeline
that's awesome all right and so where's
where's he off to is he just on job
sites
yeah he's just different states
it just varies
so back
up from the job the jobs become the bad
guy and let's not make the job the bad
guy
um
if your husband gets another job what is
that what does that do for you
well we have three we have three little
kids we have a our oldest just turned
three
and then we have a one-year-old and an
eight-month-old oh honey you are in it
huh
oh yeah how do you have a one-month-old
and an eight-month-old a one-year-old
and an eight-year-old
um they are almost exactly a year apart
oh wow
yeah
wow
what what is what was this morning like
in your home
this morning was it incredible
actually well i just opened a daycare
too so they hectic
um
so i wake my boys up the mornings are
pretty good but this morning my
three-year-old had a meltdown because i
asked him to put on an old shirt to eat
syrup with his breakfast and he wanted
to wear the shirt he had on so it was a
20-minute meltdown
three-year-olds man so you want you want
some help around the house is that fair
yes
um
i'm gonna ask you a silly question but
i'm being serious do you like your
husband you like that guy
oh yeah i love him to death
so do you want him around or do you want
a extra hand on the farm
i don't know i want him
around why tell me about that
well my boys miss him i don't care about
them what about you
it's just he's so good with the boys oh
quit tell me about your kids
tell me about you
okay i would love him here for me too to
have someone to talk to you keep
apologizing
so so far you can settle your issues
with a babysitter and like a a cell
phone
yes but it's not like uh
he's not in person
i i know i'm i'm um
i'm trying to i'm trying to i'm trying
to lead you somewhere and you're
fighting it and i'm starting to wonder
if
um there's bigger things happening
do you miss your husband
yes
do you hear what i'm saying
yeah
it's okay to miss him
and the cool thing and the tough thing
sometimes is to point to the jobs and
the things in the trash out
and that's always the thing in front of
the thing it sounds like your heart's
broken because you just miss your
boyfriend you miss that guy you love
right
and it is a
a lot of life happening that you miss
sharing it with him is that fair or am i
crazy tell me i'm crazy that's cool
i mean that's that's right
have you told him you miss him
yeah
how does that conversation go
well
we had a career session last week
because
i'm to the point where
of course i'm missing but
i'm more excited for him to come home to
help me
than i am to spend time with him that's
right you're fried and
you're exhausted as
a mother of one three-year-old whose
husband works six days a week somewhere
else much less two much less you have a
thousand
right so that's i mean you're cooked
you're fried
your body's still healing your mind and
heart are still healing and you've got
three kids to feed one of which doesn't
want to wear a shirt over
his other clothes he just wants to get
syrup on everything and go to school
so yeah that's cool here's what here's
what i'm getting at
often the job becomes the bad guy
in the fight over the job
becomes a threat to his identity it
becomes a threat to financial security
the job becomes the epicenter and that's
not the real issue here
the real issue here is
the life that we are now leading i miss
my guy
the life we are leading i can't manage
anymore because i'm out of
i'm out of soul i'm exhausted
i can't breathe when's the last time you
went to the bathroom alone
right
somebody wasn't watching you grab toilet
paper i mean like there's just basic
stuff
and
that's where that conversation has to
start
i miss you
and we
when i'm looking 20 years down the road
at the life we're building together
we're gonna have three kids that don't
know their dad
i'm gonna have lost my best friend to a
piping job
and so the question is
exactly i know you don't that's so great
but i want the i want the real bad guy
in the room to to be what we talk about
and that is i love you and i miss you
that is yeah your kids love you and they
miss you that is i need some help
and then the job because
you can get a job i don't know what that
means for everybody
but to answer your original question
you can tell them i want you to quit
your job
that's not the real thing the real thing
is
i can't i can't do the rest of our life
with you gone six days a week i miss you
and i love you
now is this a season or is this looking
starting to look like the rest of
forever
um
like are y'all trying to pay off a bunch
of debt or is he just working like crazy
because the job market's smoking hot
like where are we
i mean we're i mean we do baby steps and
stuff and that's always something we're
looking at but it's just that's just the
job he's in and
um does it pay does it pay ridiculous i
mean is it
is i mean he's not going to find a job
around home that pays him what he's
paying like what he's getting paid now
okay
and so here's here's where the what i
was talking about is real important
because you all may have to have some
really hard conversations about where
you live and how close to family and
what am i going to do and do i need to
go to school and are you going to go to
school and
all those hard hard questions
that you can have if you're together
if it's just about finding another job
man this becomes a it becomes a
a balloon you're chasing
because if it is i miss you and i love
you and i want to be connected with you
and we are drifting apart at breakneck
speed and he feels that and hears that
too
but man you can move to kansas you can
go to
wherever you can move to texas you can
move to california you can you can go
the opposite way right where everyone
else is streaming away from you can do
things like that together if it's just
go find another job man
the motivation and the the strength and
the upheaval that that causes sometimes
it's not worth it
so
this is hard i want you all to go out
and have a hey what is the next couple
years gonna look like have you you've
done that you said you had a
conversation with him how did it go not
great
well it wasn't great i mean we we talked
but he
i told him that i feel like we're
emotionally like not connected anymore
right did he did he agree with you
no he said he felt like
that was like why he was born sided
because he's like i don't feel that at
all okay
and here's what i want to tell you both
of you all have a right to that feeling
right and it's probably true for both of
you and so in a marriage when you get
those moments when i'm all in
man last night's date was incredible
last night's date was terrible when
you're all in now we got to lean into
that discomfort into that gap and figure
it out
um i
instead of
instead of trying to solve this problem
from where you're not
i'd love for you to take them out and
say hey we had this conversation in
their day we're we're further apart than
i thought emotionally we still love each
other our marriage is good i'm exhausted
all that stuff
but i thought you would feel this
disconnection and you don't so instead
of dwelling here let's do this let's
look at seven years from now
our our kids will be 10
8 and 7.
what do we want our house to look like
where do we want to live how do we want
our marriage to be
and let's get a pen and a paper and
backfill that reverse engineer and say
what would it take for us to get there
from here
have that conversation and yeah the job
may come up the job's not going to be
tenable but this conversation doesn't
start with a tactical job it starts with
my god i miss you i love you
and i know you don't feel it but i'm
telling you i'm drowning in here by
myself
and i miss my man this is my guy
thank you so much for that called on
yeah if it comes down to it you can tell
them quit your job like i don't like
your job it's taking your soul from you
want you to do something else i miss you
but i always want to call it that route
thank you so much for the call we'll be
right back on the doctor john delaney's
show
hey what's up this delony let's talk
about getting a good night's sleep it's
important for your physical health your
mental health your relation health for
your sanity you name it sleep is
important if you're not sleeping good
one of the first questions i want you to
ask is do i need a new mattress
here's how you tell are you tossing and
turning all night because you can't get
comfortable are you waking up in the
middle of the night burning hot or in
the morning does your back hurt if you
have any of these issues you may need a
new mattress
check out dream cloud it's a mattress i
have in my own house you will love it
and they're currently running their
biggest offer of all time
400 bucks in accessories plus an
additional 250 discount only for delony
listeners that's a total of 650 bucks in
accessories and savings visit
dreamcloudsleep.com deloney or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get a new mattress shipped to
your house today and you can enjoy 650
bucks in savings that's
dreamcloudsleep.com promo code
d-e-l-o-n-y
all right we're back let's go to liz in
oceanside california what's up liz hey
john how are you
so good how about you
i'm doing great
good i just uh i was just wanted to get
your feedback about
well i'm a stay-at-home mom i have two
kids one's two and one's eight months
old oh gosh can i just make the
i don't know some special sign for you
is it a how are we doing are you doing
all right
yeah i uh currently i got like four
hours of sleep last night i think it's a
conspiracy between
uh my husband and my two kids but um you
know hey
when's the last time i just asked the
last caller this when's the last time
you just casually got up from wherever
you were and just went to the bathroom
by yourself
surprisingly that's going okay still i'm
i think my two-year-old
i think my two-year-old is an
independent player enough that um i can
actually get away with that sometimes
but we'll see how long that lasts
that's so cool all right it's the little
things it's a little i remember the
first time this is me just being i'm
half ashamed and vulnerable my
uh my kids were gone and
i mean my wife was gone and my son was
like one and i had to go to the bathroom
and i remember getting up to go and then
stopping and just looking being like
oh oh he wasn't one he was just a few
months old and i was oh i guess you're i
guess i guess you're coming in i guess
you're just gonna stare at me right and
yeah i that's like seared into my soul
every time i see him even though he's
like 11 now i think do you remember that
it was super weird anyway that's cool
all right so what's up liz sorry
now you're fighting
um yeah i just wanted to get your
feedback about
how to use my iphone around my kids in a
way
that is positive for our relationship
and for their development and
i just felt a little lost on this issue
because it really wasn't something that
my parents had a chance to model for me
because it wasn't an issue didn't exist
yeah hey what an awesome question
especially what an awesome question for
with young kids like let's plan what
this thing's going to look like
downstream that's so great good for you
um all right so here uh
here's the thing we don't have a ton uh
it may exist i haven't seen it i don't
haven't seen a ton
of hard research on this it's so still
so new what we're gonna find out 20
years from now or 15 years from now
um is what happened we're playing a
giant social experiment
where we handed every parent in the
world a giant distraction and then said
go raise kids and we'll see what happens
exactly that scares me
me too
i will tell you that um
when i think back over the last decade i
literally can melt my own heart with how
i've handled this i've not done it well
and it's only been in the last couple
years that i've even gotten hyper
intentional about it and then the last
year or two since i've been telling
everybody about it every day that i've
gotten pathological about it
so here's a couple of my rules and if
you can this is just for me these aren't
rules for everybody else everybody's
life is different and i'll also say when
i was on call 24 7 365 there was a
reality to that
i had to have my phone around because i
may have to go to a hospital and i don't
have that anymore so i know that there's
everybody's different so here's a couple
of big rules
if i'm on my phone communicating if i'm
texting somebody if i'm trying to answer
an email real quick and i'm just in
passing
and one of my kids comes in
i call it out
so i say loudly
hey let me finish this i'm sending a
message
if it's appropriate i tell him who i'm
sending a work message i'm sending a
message to one of my friends i'm sending
a message to your mom hang on
and what i'm doing when that happens is
i'm acknowledging a human just walked
into the room and
more importantly it's one of the most
important humans on planet earth to me
i'm not ignoring you
one of the biggest challenges for kids
is they want to be seen they have to be
seen that's a part of their physiology
part of their biology right and so they
walk into a room and they feel like a
ghost they will begin
doing things to be seen
and so i want to make sure i see you and
i need to finish this thing because they
may not be the most important thing in
my moment right in that in that second
but they are the most important person
so the second thing is
when ever possible
i do not have that box in my hand when
my kids are in my presence
that's just become a thing for me i
watch them toggle between my eyes and
the phone and my eyes and the phone in
my eyes on the phone
and i don't like that
i don't i don't have a double-blind
study
but there's something not natural about
that they are checking
in real time
who am i looking at what's important to
dad and they have to know they're
important
um i do if i have to i've got to send a
couple of emails i got to respond to
this text messages my friends having a
challenge i got to get in the middle of
it
i do i'll go in my room and shut the
door
and then that way i can be fully present
with this phone and i can put the phone
down and then i can go back out
i'll also say i failed this regularly
liz
i kind of suck at it sure
and it's i get frustrated with myself
like i'll think to myself my kids are
right out there playing and i'm here
scrolling on some stupid thing
so um i i
have to remind myself to put this thing
down it is it's a drug for me
and um i've got to be careful about it
the other thing is i think it's
important to demonize the phone i think
the thing we need to be it's just a tool
it's just it's a hammer it's a
screwdriver so
um
i quit talking bad about it i i used to
tell my son you know there's that old
homer simpson quote that i love which is
the best part about having kids is to
teach them to hate the things that you
hate that was funny until the last four
or five years and it just hasn't been so
funny anymore um but i
don't want them to think the phone is
evil it's just a it's a tool i want them
to
watch self-control and watch where my
attention is and so
um if it's out it's out but it's not you
know what i mean
right that's what i say every time i
don't let my my son uh my my son is my
two-year-old i don't ever let him just
hold my phone or play with my phone
right yes and so i um i always tell him
if he gets it like hey mommy's phone is
not it's not a toy it's a tool yes and
so and it's for adults it's for adults
right
and so as we get older like i'll tell my
kids hey that that's an adult movie this
is
you know i got to watch the new
chappelle special this is a this is an
adult show this is not for kids and this
is adult talk time this is when me and
your mom are talking y'all go play
my kids understand that language that
adults have conversations that are not
for them that they're not included in
and so this goes into that bucket and
this is an adult tool same as when we're
hunting and i've got gun like those i
handle those right and so it just
becomes one of those things it's just
something to be aware of
um
what are you worried about when it comes
to how you handle this stuff
yeah i'm just uh really worried about
messing this up um no i i have that same
gut instinct i that that's been creeping
up more and more um
as my two-year-old especially is getting
you know more more and more aware
i'm afraid that he is going to feel
um like i'm not present like i'm
even your show has been a problem john
i've had to turn off your show and be
because i could tell there's like a
podcast running in the background
even if i'm just not holding my phone he
knows that my mental space is somewhere
else yes
so i've had to limit like okay maybe i
should just listen to one podcast in the
morning or not at all
till his nap time or something but i'm
gonna stop you right there this show is
way more important than any kid you i
don't know what
way more important than your children
um okay so you know what you're
describing i've never heard it described
this way but you just did it perfectly
let's say you have a parent with an
alcohol addiction or an opioid addiction
and they're sitting on the couch
and a kid sees them
hears them
and can touch them
but a kid can feel they are com in
another place
right and it becomes like a numbing
mechanism almost i think it exactly and
the kids will solve for they will try to
make that leap to that connection with
their parent for the rest of their life
and if you're holding a phone it's the
same they see you they hear you
they can touch your leg
but you're gone you're not there and so
yeah your instinct is so right
i think the cool thing we can all do we
can all work on this
is
coming up with some practices
do the phone go in the drawer are there
times when i'm gonna check my phone and
this is hard for a stay-at-home mom
because now you're talking about
disconnecting yourself from the rest of
the world right
right and it's it's lonely it's true
yeah it's it can be
like i just found myself listening to a
podcast a ton because i love learning
and i love growing in knowledge and how
to be a good parent
and and all these good things and
there's so many good things to listen to
but can i can i tell you can i tell you
the one insidious thing
yeah here's the one insidious thing
it's learning and growing is cool
but
podcast voices of which i am one
bypasses all of your other senses
so up until
75 years ago
if you were communicating with somebody
you saw them they're in your presence
they might even be on a stage far away
but they were with you
and just 75 years ago when we came up
with the radio or maybe 100 years ago i
don't remember
we started bypassing that and our brains
are dealing with something that they are
not designed to deal with which is
somebody's voice pipe directly into
their into your brain
and why am i telling you this it is cool
to learn it is cool to get connected
it's cool to figure things out it's cool
to learn new tools and things
but you're also getting a cheap
substitute for connection
there's parts of your brain and body
that you and i are friends and we've
never even met
um absolutely there are times i found
myself in the past reaching out to a
podcast just because i missed a voice
you know i mean i miss the inside jokes
and i should be having those real people
which is hard for a mom who's staying at
home with two little ones two two years
and younger and so here's the here's
what i want you to focus on focus on
where and when am i fully present if i'm
gonna be on the phone with my friends i
wanna be fully on the phone with my
friends
totally
if i'm gonna respond to texts and emails
and get the hilarious memes and ask the
questions about like what does this rash
look like i want to be fully in that
conversation and when i'm not fully
there i want to be fully with my kids
and if i'm not fully with my kids i want
to be fully in the book or in the
podcast i'm listening to not doing 10
things at once because you know we all
know now that um
that toggling back and forth
multitasking is a myth it's not real
it's just your brain going back and back
and back and back back and forth
and so where can you are fully present
does that make sense
yes
so
i think
maybe let's do this and i'm i'm thinking
this out loud with you because i'm a
parent who struggles with this too
maybe instead of wondering what we do
with the phone which is real i'm not
going to give my kids phones even my
middle schoolers come back and said man
i really thank you
i'm not going to get my kids phones
that's all simple i'm going to continue
to work on
being connected with my kid making sure
they see that i see them
but beneath that let's forget the phone
when i'm where i'm at i want to be fully
present wherever i'm at
when i'm when as soon as i get on a
plane to go speak somewhere i'm gonna be
fully there because missing i guess miss
my kids
that doesn't help me see them that
doesn't help me honor the people i'm
going to speak to it just makes me feel
there so i'm going to be all in i'm
going to be when i go to new city i'm
going to enjoy myself there i'm going to
enjoy it when i'm back at home i'm going
to be fully at home does that make sense
yep i'm talking to my friends let's be
there so you give me i'm gonna let you
turn the tables you give me a practice
that i'm gonna agree to do
when it comes to having two little kids
in the house and phones
you tell me and i'll be all in
okay let's see
well i thought of this
a couple days ago i was thinking maybe
if i kept my drawer i kept my phone
in my bedroom drawer and turn all the
way up so i can hear it it's you know
something if my husband calls or
something and i really need to get it
um
but just sort of keeping it in there and
not having it readily accessible
around me just for the morning until
until nap time
so what time is nap time
that's the one it's at one after lunch
okay if you can make it till noon
man that's some willpower you're not
even a real
all right so here's the deal here's
here's the thing i'm in i'm in so i'm
going to
i've got my social media on my work
phones it's on one other thing
my commitment for the next 30 days is
that phone does not leave my truck
when i get home it stays in the car and
then i will see it again the next day
and so i won't mess with it in the
morning that's my commitment for 30 days
cool
cool second thing is my phone will go in
a drawer
hey that's so dumb for me my
self-service doesn't even work that's
such a [ __ ] that i carry it around
my phone is going to go in a drawer
and i will check it at intervals
throughout the afternoon or evening and
i will not pick it up check it before i
go to work that way i can be fully
present with myself fully present with
my morning routine to my spiritual stuff
and with my family amen you in
i'm in okay promise me that you will not
go off on an island though you need
other people that means you may have to
invite people over
yeah okay
you may have to be weird and invite
friends over i don't know if that's
legal in california but you've got to
have hosting yeah good so set up a
couple of mornings a week tell someone
to bring their weird little kid over and
y'all can just stare at each other no
cleaning up no makeup no nothing you
bring whatever coffee you got left and
i'll i got a banana and a half left and
let's just hang out
is that cool
yeah that sounds good oh my gosh liz we
are changing the world
good lit oh you just made me happy all
right challenge accepted to everyone
listening phone's in the drawer no
social media before work let's try that
for 30 days and see what happens here's
what's gonna happen you're gonna sleep
better your life's gonna be better
you're gonna have better sex with your
spouse your kids are gonna like you and
all that kind of stuff but let's pretend
we don't know what's gonna happen and
let's go from there we'll be right back
on the dr john dolone's show
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes like a
lightning bolt i've been helping folks
101 for years but i wanted to create
something that everyone could use
anywhere at any time so i created a free
guided meditation it's not really a
meditation but really me just walking
with you through your anxiety alarms
from start to finish i'll guide you
through a breathing exercise and show
you how to lean in listen and head
towards healing it is free and it's for
everyone you can download this guided
meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right we are back hey i want to
address an email i get this email a lot
and
um let's just jump right into it this
one's from gordon
says i'm asking your thoughts on
opposite sex friends
and what are good boundaries in marriage
um man this is such a great question i
get this all the time and
it it doesn't have to be it can be
anybody you're attracted to anybody that
um
otherwise would be weird because you're
married you've got somebody
who you pledged your allegiance to for
the rest of your life and it may be that
your
partner at work your co-worker is
someone of the opposite gender someone
who's attracted to you somebody who is
cool to hang out with and you end up
spending eight hours a day with them you
actually spend more time with that
person at work than you do with your own
spouse happens a lot
um it may be like hey we are in the
middle of a project let's go grab lunch
real quick let's just run um hey i gotta
get to work early tomorrow you grab
coffee and let's whatever hey did you
hear that new band they are awesome
check this out
hey we had to have this really hard hr
conversation we got to go through this
and that
workplace
solving problems together
accomplishing projects together
um
it can slowly it could be an intimate
interaction right you're talking about
things that drive you crazy that are
hard you shed tears together you cheer
together you you hit your goals together
you fail together things you just get
messy
so for me here's the the two or three
driving things
number one
in my past i've known ooh i'm getting on
dangerous ground
when i keep secrets
when i think
i need to delete that
not that somebody no one's you know i'm
not sexting anything like that i'm
saying
when i've got private jokes
that i don't try to fill my wife in on
um
i have a few friends in my life who are
very close to me that i've had friends
for years and they are wives of my
buddies
my wife is friends with that intimate
group of people i mean we have been ride
or die for years and years and years
um
i trust them with my children i trust
them with my life
they are free to
communicate with my wife that's just
there's a an intimacy there
um
uh kelly and i exchanged messages
regularly hey this call is coming in
make sure you check i just sent the call
sheet make sure that hey tomorrow's show
is gonna be at this time
that's just part of being in the
business world together and working on a
project together
it's when that phone dings and i see it
and i delete it really fast or i think
ooh
it's a little bit too far
or
man i really hope so and so text today
oh i sent a meme that i think is
hilarious and i can't wait can't wait
can't wait can't wait till see if they
get the joke or if they respond
it's when suddenly i realize oh man i
think i'm investing more in that
friendship
than my marriage that's when we
things start getting messy
um
when in this in the last few years when
i go if i have to go grab coffee with
somebody if i have lunch with somebody i
actually text my wife now hey i'm going
to grab lunch with so and so i'm gonna
run grab coffee with so-and-so
in fact i don't even do that anymore um
i take a group of people it just keeps
everything clean i don't know what's
going on in other people's lives i don't
know what's going on in their hearts and
in their minds and in their marriages
and in their friendships and in their
dating relationships i don't know
and i don't want to get into all that
mess
i am responsible for taking care of my
home and my marriage and so i'm going to
keep stuff as above board as possible
here's what i want to call out though
that can be how good old boy networks
get perpetuated
one of my favorite stories ever i won't
use her name she's so awesome she's one
of my favorite
leaders ever
she was um a leader at a university and
she was always the only woman at the
table
she was a riot one of the funniest
funniest people i've ever met much less
people that i worked for much less
a senior executive who's a woman
but she tells this hilarious story about
how they were around a board room and
they were going at it it was a a heavy
meeting there was a lot of hard opinions
people were frustrated and they were
loud and they were getting back on each
other and
they took a break hey we gotta let's
just take a break let's go get coffee
and let's go to the bathroom
so she says all these men get up and
pile in and go into the bathroom
i'm stuck getting coffee by myself
and before before i get coffee i go run
to the ladies room
i go in the bathroom
and i hear them
through the wall they're still having
the meeting
they're still talking about what
so-and-so said and what about this and
we can't afford that and we're gonna
have to cut our budgets by this percent
she said i got done going bathroom and i
just walked right around and i kicked
that door open
and said if y'all are still having this
if we're still having this meeting i'm
coming in
and to which all the men were like oh
sorry sorry we'll be out quickly and she
laughed and they laughed
and then they all came out and they sat
down back down at the table and
continued the meeting
why is that important
it can be a way to perpetuate the good
old boys club oh i don't i don't go to
lunches i don't do these things um this
is just i i don't go to lunches with
anybody other than my husband and i
think that's wise i think that's so wise
and it's a way to perpetuate the gap in
the workplace so here's here's my
solution to that
number one don't have meetings over
lunch give yourself a break during the
day if you're working that much for an
extended period of time i get their
seasons but if you were working like
that man you're on a pace for burnout
just decide
i i take private lunches man i don't
work through lunch number two take
groups with you go in groups man keep
everything above board
laugh together as a group
share and exchange things as a group
like be open and vulnerable with each
other as a group
it's just wise
there is no he said she said i felt
uncomfortable
uh he asked this question or she made
this comment and now we're in a mess
everybody keeps their hands above board
this isn't me being prude this isn't me
being old school this is me trying to be
wise
and
to keep equality in mind
now
could i go grab lunch with my friend
melissa
my oldest buddies todd's wife yeah
i could
would todd grab lunch with my wife
absolutely i wouldn't think twice about
it in fact i would love that he's
a lot more level-headed and wise than i
am i think they're probably good for my
wife's soul
my friend john taking my yes all that
yes yes yes
i'm talking about workplace stuff i'm
talking about secrets i'm talking about
sneaking around i'm talking about that
moment when you realize
i hope
my workplace friend texts me more than i
hope my wife does that's when you're in
dangerous ground
so whatever rules you put in place for
your workplace whatever rules you put in
place with your spouse it goes back to
intentionality have the conversation
with your spouse you may have been going
to coffee with your workmate for years
and you didn't even know your wife has
no idea your husband has no idea and you
tell them like no i don't do that it
makes me feel uncomfortable i feel weird
now you gotta have a conversation and
it's not about oh you don't trust me
it's not about that
it's about playing with fire it's about
being safe it's about being wise
it's about you're going to put yourself
in a position that you've got no cover
that somebody can say anything about you
and it's just he said she said or he
said he said or she said she
she shed she shed that's i don't she
shed she shed
i don't know i feel like we just we just
dumped into a home depot commercial real
real quick it got weird you all know
what i'm saying be wise don't keep
secrets be intentional go in groups
there you go so just go ahead and leave
all your
mean comments below
might as well join the join the parade
all right as we wrap up today's show
i think this is james favorite song of
all time
i think he likes this song because it
used to used to play offender but let's
all understand that tom delong changed
to gibson he has his own gibson line now
which is
even his fender just had one humbucker
pick up in it right i'm not really a
blink fan so i don't know these things
but cody has his signature strat and i
think it just has one humbucker so it's
not really offender after all cody has a
signature what do you feel about that
america listening pause let's take a
time out here
what do you think about buying signature
guitars i feel like that's i have two of
them do you yeah okay so here's my
initial thought
whenever i go to a baseball game and i
see another grown man wearing a shirt
with another grown man's name on the
back i always feel weird about that like
so whenever i think
like hey this is my special guitar you
should buy it too
that's not the same
because it's i don't buy them for the
player in fact like i have a jmaskus
jazz master of course you do and i
don't care anything about jay mascus
really like i think you don't like some
dinosaur junior well i mean i like some
of their songs but i didn't buy it
because of him i bought it because it's
a cool cheap guitar and same with my
bass i have i i like the the bass player
but i bought it for the guitar it just
happens to be a signature ah okay that's
fair that's fair and there's something
different about like
hey guys look i've got another grown man
unless they just bought it for the shirt
quality is excellent and they just it
just so happen to have it just
altuve's name on the back or what yeah
probably not all right time in america
all right so as we wrap up today's show
blink 182 i think this is off the enema
of the state record
maybe the greatest title of all time
song is called all the small things and
it goes like this
all the
small things
truth care
truth brings i'll take
one lift your ride best trip always
i know
you'll be at my show watching
waiting commiserating
say it ain't so
i will not go
turn the lights off carry me home now
here's the good part
[Music]
we are not allowing ourselves to sleep
right here on the dr john delaney show
[Music]